[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like buttons the only way the
YouTube algorithm notices
me the J by Stephen King is a short
story set sometime around the year
2300 by this time humankind has begun
the colonization of our solar system
this was made possible by a world
changing piece of technology invented in
the80s the Jaun the word J was first
used in Alfred bester's 1956 science
fiction novel The Stars my destination
in this novel humans have access to
personal teleporters teleporting was
referred to as jaunting in this novel
Stephen King takes the idea of the jaunt
and twists it into something not merely
dark but horrifying Beyond
Comprehension the idea of teleportation
has been common in science fiction for
many decades and the fears associated
with it are not unexplored cronenberg's
famous the fly explores the horror of a
teleportation experiment gone wrong in
which the main character's DNA is
accidentally mixed with an insect
teleporters have featured prominently in
Star Trek since its original release in
1965 and it's never been fully clear if
the teleporters allow for a continuous
stream of Consciousness or if they are
simply killing the original person and
rematerializing an exact copy with
copied memories in a different place the
Jun also considers What Becomes Of
Consciousness during
teleportation but in a different way to
understand you have to learn how the the
Jaun was first invented in this story by
a man named Victor karon in this story
man begins to run out of oil and this of
course leads to a huge energy crisis it
mentions that 10,000 people in America
froze one year because there was nothing
they could do to heat their homes the
jot was instrumental in solving this
energy crisis because there was oil on
Mars Victor karon was a scientist who
had a contract with the government he
basically invented the J by accident
first he teleports his fingers pushing
them through the threshold and pulling
them back he's fine then he teleports a
pencil and then Keys then a watch and
then a mouse but the mouse is where
things get really really
weird karon touched the mouse it was
like touching something inert packed
stra straw or sawdust perhaps except for
the aspirating sides the mouse did not
look around at karon it stared Straight
Ahead he had thrown in a squirming very
frisky and Alive little animal here was
something that seemed to be a living
waxwork likeness of a mouse Kon snapped
his fingers in front of the mouse's
small pink eyes it blinked and fell dead
on its side karon's measurements
indicated that no time Distortion
happened between the time of entering
the jaunt and the time of leaving it at
least not physically and yet all living
creatures who were jaunted ultimately
died even though physically they
appeared perfectly healthy sensory input
he thought almost randomly when they go
through they see something hear
something touch
something God maybe even smell something
that literally kills them
what what became of Consciousness when
Crossing through the jaunt what lied
within that space between that was so
terrible that life simply gave up upon
re-entering the Physical Realm the
animals could not speak but a human
could when the government got wind of
what karun was doing it was only a
matter of time before human trials would
begin and of course they used
prisoners karon basically figured out
that if you sent an animal or person
through sleeping then when they came
through on the other side they were fine
but they still wanted to know what would
happen if you sent a person in awake so
they got a man named Rudy FAA to
volunteer he was a prisoner sentenced to
death who had murdered a bunch of people
and in exchange for
doing the ja awake they would allow him
to leave and be let free of all charges
if he
survived he came through alive but Rudy
FAA was in no condition to eat his
chicken dinner and the space it took to
J across 2 miles pegged at
0.00000000 67th of a second by a
computer faa's hair had turned Snow
White his face had not changed in any
physical way it was not lined or JY or
wasted but it gave the impression of
great almost incredible
age fagia shuffled out of the portal his
eyes bulging blankly his mouth twitching
his hands splayed out in front of him
presently he begin to
drool the scientists who had gathered
around him Drew away and know Mark
really doubted if any of them had talked
they knew about the rats after all and
the guinea pigs and the hamsters any
animal in fact with more brains than
your average flatworm they must have
felt a bit like those German scientist
who tried to impregnate Jewish women
with the sperm of German Shepherds what
happened one of the scientists shouted
it was the only question that FASA had a
chance to
answer it's eternity in there he said
and Dro dead of what was diagnosed as a
massive heart attack the scientists for
gathered there were left with his corpse
and that strange and awful dying
declaration it's eternity in there now
if you saw my Halloween special from
last month then you know that all of
Stephen King's books are connected in a
giant
macroverse and other Stephen King
stories like it do mention that people's
hair turns white when they look into
into the macroverse because of the
cosmic Madness of it all but I think
there's also another implication here I
think that what Consciousness actually
comes face to face with within the Jaun
is eternity itself a single mind no body
all alone and infinite nothingness for
an eternity in that time the Mind begins
to cannibalize itself the body is
transported
instantaneously but the mind is left in
this void with only itself for an
eternity and is suddenly snapped back
into existence and it caves in upon
Itself by the year 2300 traveling
through use of the jaunt is common it is
how we have colonized planets but all
travelers still have to be put to sleep
with a gas before traveling in the
beginning of the story we are introduced
to a man who is about to travel with his
family through use of the jaunt and he
recounts the story of Victor karon to
his children explaining that the reason
they are put to sleep is because
eternity waits for them should they
remain conscious hearing this and
knowing this his 12-year-old son
develops a deadly case of curiosity and
upon the completion of the John
they all awake to find something
devastating beside Ricky his sister
still mercifully slept the thing that
had been his son bounced and rived in
its jaunt couch a 12-year-old boy with a
snow white fall of hair and eyes which
were incredibly ancient the corny is
gone a sickly yellow here was a creature
older than th masquerading as a boy and
yet it bounced and wed with the kind of
Horrid obscene Glee and its choked
lunatic cackles the ja attendants Drew
back in Terror some of them fled
although they had been trained to cope
with just such an unthinkable
eventuality the old young legs twitched
and quivered claw hands beat and twisted
and danced on the air abruptly they
descended and the thing that had been
his son began to Claw at its face longer
than you think Dad it cackled longer
than you think held my breath when they
gave me the gas I wanted to see I saw I
saw longer than you think cackling and
screeching the thing on the Jaun couch
suddenly clawed its own eyes out blood
gout it the recovery room was an Avary
of screaming voices now longer than you
think Dad I saw long J longer than you
think it said other things before the
jot attendants were finally able to Bear
it away rolling its couch swiftly away
as it screamed and cloged at its eyes
that had seen the unseeable forever and
ever it said other things and then it be
to scream but Mark oats didn't hear it
because by then he was screaming
himself so we've heard the notion that
Consciousness exists because there is at
some point some being that contained all
of
Consciousness and because it was alone
being the only thing
it split itself so that it would no
longer be alone imagine being just a
mind in nothing for eternity no body no
stimulus just
existence the human mind was meant to
exist for about 80 years and then end it
wasn't meant to be stretched thin across
all of eternity I really love this story
because it's about technology and the
risks and fears associated with it and
it also has that element of cosmic
horror the unthinkable looking into the
unknowable and being scarred by and
that's of course a very lovecraftian
idea so the Skeleton Crew is a great
collection of stories it also includes
the Mist which I talked about in my
Halloween special definitely check it
out if you like these kinds of sto
thanks so much for watching
guys if you'd like to do more to keep
this channel afloat consider donating
through the PayPal Link in the
description or checking out our patreon
thanks guys so
[Music]
much